this week Abercrombie and Fitch
announced they would no longer have
shirtless models posing outside their
stores no more that we're getting rid of
the shirtless miles where they are
saying goodbye as they're being led away
anyway the move is part of a general
overhaul of the chains business model
I'm sorry I'm sorry did you say they
were getting rid of their shirtless
models
[Applause]
so no more peace a staying in the land
in front of stores taking pictures with
shoppers right
no no nothing no more of that
[Applause]
stop stop just stop the music no they're
phasing that whole thing out they're
getting rid of it
what about bailiffs models the get rid
of those pantless models no no one no
one mentioned anything about pantless
models alright alright well
[Applause]
good evening ladies and gentlemen you're
probably wondering why I just stopped
that sketch using a graphic please stand
by a logo that hasn't been used in over
60 years it's a little thing I call
standards we all knew where that sketch
was headed so I cut it off before you
had to see more why because I want my
show to rise above that kind of broad
frat humor it's more at home in a
beginner level improv class and I invite
other shows to follow my lead maybe if
we all raise our standards we could pull
our permissive anything-goes culture
[Applause]
from the new CBS series The Odd Couple
Matthew Perry will be joining us
sir the new CW series izombie rose
McIver is on the show
he's our guest Shawn Mendes
we'll be right back stick around you
minutes do it wasn't that a great clip
subscribe to my youtube channel for an
endless supply of me
[Laughter]